pas de fin en vue à cette vague de criminalité
tout le monde sait que les solutions Fang sont pour toujours
ne viennent pas plus tard oui vous avez été très
chanceux des fragments de ferme ici et ici
monsieur le lobe temporal y aura-t-il une
défense si quelque chose d'inhabituel se produit je
veux que vous me laissiez maintenant  tout de suite
[Musique]
n'a jamais été la victime tais-toi vieil homme
pour ne pas être là
ils étaient là dont nous parlons chez
Lucy
j'ai entendu dire qu'il n'y avait pas une sorte de justicier
ou quelque chose pour lui montrer qu'il affrontait le
gang
oh  ouais
tu n'appelles pas que le diable est parti 10 20
tonnes où Oh Lucy je vais
revenir à pied
spécialement pour les enfants
[Musique]